well welcome everyone the name of this
session is the story behind the kool-aid
Jim Jones and Peoples Temple my name is
Gilbert Garcia I'm the Metro columnist
at the San Antonio express-news and I'm
really pleased to be here as a I wanted
before we get started I wanted to also
mention to you that we're going to make
sure that we leave about 10 minutes
toward the end for for questions from
the audience and if you have a question
please go to that mic there in the
center of the room and also after the
session is over if you want to get your
book signed by Jeff Winn
the place to go is there's a Barnes &
Noble book tent outside so that's that's
where you'll go to get that done so
we're gonna get started a person to my
right is Jeff Winn he's a best-selling
award-winning author and former
journalist based in Fort Worth and he's
a member of the Texas literary Hall of
Fame
he's written 19 books over the years and
he's proven himself equally adept at
writing fiction and nonfiction those
books include Manson the life and times
of Charles Manson go down together the
true untold story of Bonnie and Clyde
and the last gunfight the real story of
a shootout the OK Corral and how it
changed the American West his new book
the road to Jonestown Jim Jones and
Peoples Temple is the definitive account
of the life of one of the most
fascinating and controversial religious
figures of the 20th century and how the
idealistic socially conscious movements
that Jim Jones created came to a
horrific end in Guyana now Jeff you and
I talked a little bit the other day
about the fact that when you when you
write a nonfiction book you tend to pick
an area that you're interested in
writing and then you decide what figure
or what events from that period
you think maybe kind of helps to define
that era or would be a really good sort
of entree into into looking at that
period before this you wrote about the
60s wrote about Charles Manson in
looking at the 70s you decided to focus
on Jim Jones and Peoples Temple what was
it about him and that movement that you
thought kind of a captured that era one
of the things that I think is important
is if we're going to be writing about a
time in a mirror
in history we want to pick an iconic
individual or event that folks will
remember from that time sometimes it can
be a joyful event the book that I'm
working on now for Simon & Schuster
doesn't involve death it it involves
America right after the turn of the 20th
century when inventions were coming into
full flower in the country was just
aghast at all these great things moving
them into the modern times but when I
finished the manson book which was
really about the 1960s in america and i
know i'm the only person in the room
that's old enough to remember the 60s I
was there the rest of you will have to
take my word I wanted then to look at
what happens next in America in the
1960s the country almost comes apart the
social schisms seem so vast that can we
ever be a United people again and I
think many Americans came out of the 60s
suspicious of government of big business
and even of the church so I wanted to
find out for myself and hopefully for
readers how do the 60s segue into the
70s and I decided there's just two
events from the 1970s that that
everybody pretty much remembers now and
the first was Watergate and I looked at
that and I thought there have been over
400 books
I don't think there's anything new that
I can bring to this and the other great
part of American history that we all
know a phrase we've all used don't drink
the kool-aid and yet it wasn't kool-aid
many of the people that day did not
choose to drink it they were held down
and forcibly injected the word for that
is murder and most amazingly of all Jim
Jones and Peoples Temple was never a
freak show we think today most of us
that oh it was just some clearly lunatic
leader and a bunch of mindless folks who
follow him into certain doom and nothing
could be further from the truth so the
purpose of this book there's two number
one is to look at how American history
is evolving nothing happens in a vacuum
how do the 50s the 60s lead into the 70s
make it possible for someone like Jim
Jones to emerge and second who were
these people who followed him what
reason did they have and of course as it
turns out many of them were amazingly
talented intelligent socially conscious
people who were trying very much to help
bring about a better world so those were
the two things were trying to get at in
the book and I'm very grateful to the
San Antonio Book Festival and for
Gilbert for giving us this chance to
talk about that for a little bit well
along those lines you know whether the
country the contradictions with Jim
Jones that kind of fascinates me is on
one level you know he grew up in a small
Indiana town and he was kind of a
religious prodigy I mean he he could
quote biblical passages you know but by
memory and he would run from one church
service to another as Jeff it talks
about in the book he'd go from one
church service to another on a Sunday to
try to catch as many as he could
and yet there was also the side to him
where he said he said this late I think
his life and his wife is was quoted as
saying basically the same thing that he
never really believed in God that he was
that really that he used religion as a
way to infiltrate uh the you know I
guess maybe to - he wanted to to spread
the cut the concept of socialism and he
used religion as a way to do it and I
guess my question is what is your
sentiment was obviously he understood a
lot about what really effect that
religion had on people and he hits read
the Bible and he knew so much about it
what do you think his belief system was
I think that like most of us Jim Jones
had an evolving belief system there's no
way we can ever look into anybody's
heart and say this person definitely
believes what he's saying now or this
person is making it all up
to understand Jones we have to look at
his whole life not just the notorious
last few years that we all remember so I
want you to imagine that you're a little
boy growing up in Lynn Indiana which is
up in the northwest part of the state
it's rural and your father is a very
disabled World War one vet who's been
gassed and can hardly talk and hardly
speak your mother is an outspoken rebel
who believes that she has lived hundreds
of lives and was a great woman in a
previous life and it was ordained to her
in a dream that she should give birth to
the greatest man who ever lived
and would change the world so here he is
growing up in this little tiny town
where religion is the basis of existence
everybody goes to church less than a
thousand people five churches in town
and here's this little boy who spends
ten minutes with the Nazarenes and then
he wants to run over and have some more
time with the Methodists and don't
forget the Baptist are just around the
corner
and yet he's also being told at home
that this is your latest incarnation
you're going to do great things and then
Jones when he decides to enter the
ministry does it in Indianapolis and
this is one of the most segregated
cities in America in the 1940s early
1950s they have laws passed that seem
benign things like nobody can buy a
house in the neighborhood unless the
majority of the homeowners in that block
agreed to the sale and how does that let
black people buy into a white
neighborhood it doesn't Jim Jones
started his ministry in a little
storefront Church in Indianapolis with a
few older black people who remembered
crosses being burned on lawns for whom
Jim Crow was every bit as real as Jesus
Christ and he did amazing things within
10 years Jim Jones virtually
single-handed integrated one of the most
racist major cities in America and he's
doing this 15 years before the Civil
Rights Act makes it mandatory I have
talked to old people in Indianapolis who
say that without Jim Jones their lives
would have been worthless and they don't
care what he did later did he believe in
God then I can't tell you what I can
tell you is that in the name of God he
accomplished the kinds of great things
that would if he had been hit by a car
and killed in the 1950s would make him
remember today as one of the heroes of
the early civil rights movement and he
would have deserved it later he's saying
I never believed in God at all I only
used it to bring people in to follow me
and to get a social platform
we talked about him we remember only the
awful end but let's also consider the
fact this is a man who also in his early
career did more good than almost anybody
else you're ever going to meet he was a
contradiction then he's a contradiction
now yeah and and you know one of the
things that's that's interesting as you
said he was doing so many things as far
as social justice he was taking care of
the elder they didn't I think he and his
wife had a nursing home several several
yeah and they did there was so much good
work that they did and I don't think
they were real too conscious about about
money I mean he tended to whatever money
he had early on at least he tended to
use for higher purposes but even early
on you know you get the sense from from
your book that the the darker qualities
that would eventually prove to be his
undoing that you could see them in there
there was a paranoia of possessiveness
that that came out and one of the
stories that fascinated me we talked the
other day about this was his wife had a
cousin who they took in and was living
with them and he was I think the cousin
was like 11 years old
and Jim was only in his early 20s at the
time and Jim wanted to adopt the boy and
he'd the boy didn't want it didn't want
that and Jim got furious and angry and
it became a really ugly situation and in
some ways Jim when I look at like
letters that you that you quote where
he's writing if one person was going to
leave the church this is what he was
still in Indiana and sixty's he would
write these you know long letters and
get very upset it almost reminded me of
the performer who has you know 5000
cheering fans in the audience but all
they can focus on is that one person in
the crowd with their arms crossed who's
you know who is browning it Jim seemed
to obsess about there was some deep
sense of rejection that he had to do you
think that was correct there was
something in his nature where he just he
couldn't handle anyone leaving or anyone
rejecting it the reason we look at a
person's life demagogue like Jim Jones
we look at the whole life is we look
back to see what clues are there of
what's to come and what you had was a
man who was always possessive of
everything if you were a member of his
church
that meant that you belong to him
forever as far as he was concerned but
he carried that into other aspects of
his life I mean I have talked to his
high school sweetheart you know if you
date Jim Jones by God you're his and he
meant it if one person when he had
thousands of followers filling an
auditorium but his rule was you couldn't
get up and leave hid scheduled bathroom
breaks every hour or so but if someone
had to get up if let's say someone's
cellphone had gone off in the middle of
a program he would have called down the
power of the Lord ma'am you don't have
to worry about that we're friendlier
here but the whole the whole idea of Jim
Jones was that he did these great things
and yet at the same time he's looking
always to build himself a basis for
power and influence he wants to be the
one in charge
his cousin gene who grew up with him
right down the block
told me stories of how during World War
two
Jimmy is 11 12 years old all the other
kids in Lynn Indiana all the boys there
Allied soldiers you know they're Patton
or they're Montgomery and they're
they're fighting they're fake wars and
winning
Jimmy is fascinated with the Nazis he
loves the way Hitler has the crowds
hanging on every word he's sort of the
middle-aged cousin and they're a bunch
of Jones kids in town there's like 25
and he forces all the younger Joneses to
march for him under his command and they
have to goose-step if they don't
goose-step right he's got his switch and
he's slamming their legs with the switch
and did that till their mothers found
out and he's fascinated when Hitler
commits suicide
that this is Hitler thumbing his nose at
the enemies surrounding him that when
this great leader came to the end and it
was going to be all over would not give
his enemies the satisfaction of
capturing him do you have any wonder why
the hair stood up on my arms when I'm
hearing these stories if you really want
to understand a controversial figure I
promise you look back in their lives
you're going to see the pattern well you
know eventually he moved the people's
temple from Indiana to California along
the way in the early sixties he thought
about setting up a colony in Brazil he
spent a couple of years there and I
think he was I think he hated being away
because he didn't want anybody else to
be to take over services his church
because he was very competitive and he
had to be in control but that didn't
work out he ended up in California in
the 70s and to give you a sense of the
situation that he was in I mean he was
he had become so politically powerful
there that you had George Moscone the
the the mayor of San Francisco made him
chair of the the City Housing Authority
in the mid seventies in 1976 there was a
political event when Jimmy Carter is
running for president and he speaks
there was Rosalyn Carter and I think he
pretty much stole the show that Thursday
and I and from I think he had a private
dinner with Rosalyn Carter later he
there were letters of the kind of
letters for recommendation written on
his behalf by Rosalyn Carter by Walter
Mondale who by this point had become the
vice president so he's a person who had
a lot of political power and influence
but at the same time there was you know
he had become very controversial they
were starting to be articles and they
were certain to be scrutiny of some of
the questionable behavior that was
happening there so it was in this
context that he decided to move to gaya
right and this is if you can talk a
little bit about what what the situation
was what his thinking was what he was
trying to create in moving the People's
Temple to the jungles of South America
well let's take ourselves back to the
1960s in America and again I know most
of you will have to use your imagination
so bear with me
people's temple first in Indianapolis
and then in California gains our
reputation for doing great positive
things they have drug treatment programs
when drugs this is the first time it's a
rampant disease in America they have not
only free restaurants where if you're
hungry you can go in and be fed no
questions asked and then after you've
had your meal you're taken to their
clothing store where you can pick out
clothes no charge they even went so far
is for ghetto kids to pay to send them
to college full ride these are kids who
otherwise the only education they would
have gotten would have been on the
streets in the riots that we're going on
in America at that time People's Temple
is taking them placing them in school
paying for everything giving them a
chance at life is it any wonder that
politicians want to attach themselves to
this particularly let's think in San
Francisco in the 1960s and the city's
changing for years the power structure
has been the business leaders downtown
they're the ones that make the decision
everybody is going to come to San
Francisco because tourism is going to be
our big industry and we want the
tourists who come to see all the great
stuff we want to see Chinatown you know
we want them to look at the beautiful
Bay the Golden Gate Bridge we don't want
them seeing anything unsightly in San
Francisco there is a sizeable black
ghetto and the powers that be cooler
than hell begin a reclamation project
where the city is going to if it has to
take control of all the land and it's
going to knock down all these unsightly
slums going to put in some freeways in
their place so that tourists can get
in and out of town quicker and then
maybe we'll put up some nice shopping
areas you know souvenir stands so
suddenly you have this sizable minority
group they're being dispossessed get the
hell out of here
we don't want you they have no political
voice and suddenly here comes this man
and his church first of all saying all
of you matter you're important if you
join us you will get complete respect we
will help you educate your children so
they don't have to live lives in the
ghetto and we will work together and we
will improve your lives Jones always
bragged about Peoples Temple that it is
a church where you get something now
other you know other ministers would say
you know everything in life you put up
with some day you're going to go to
heaven it would be wonderful Jim Jones
said if you're in this church we're
going to improve things now but they
didn't do it
confrontationally anybody here ever here
are the Black Panthers well I promise
you in California in the 1960s early
1970s they caused fear they were
organized they didn't back down they
were scary black people and now you get
People's Temple which is a mixed-race
congregation blacks whites Hispanics
people mingling together is equals and
they want to get involved publicly by
doing positive things George Moscone
running for mayor of San Francisco
knowing he's got big business against
him is only going to win if he can
gather all the discarded parts of the
population make a new coalition get them
out to vote who is he going to go to who
can do that but Jim Jones and
Jones not only delivers he not only gets
his people loading he lends the
Greyhound buses the fleet of buses
belonging to people's temple - the
Mosconi campaign so you can pick up my
scone ii voters anywhere in town even if
there's no other transportation get him
to a voting booth Jim Jones jr. who was
so wonderful contributing to this book
sat in on the meeting where Jones
explained to masconi's people you've got
a lot of registered San Francisco voters
living in Los Angeles let's send a
couple buses down there on Election Day
bring him back George Moscone wins by a
scant few thousand votes any wonder who
made it possible and who expects quid
pro quo now that's how jim jones would
accomplish things not by tearing down
not by threatening it's look at all the
positive things we can do together and I
have to ask you you are intelligent
folks right your readers you're socially
committed if there was someone in San
Antonio in those tumultuously said I
really can bring people together and
we're going to do fine things we're not
going to tear down we're going to build
up pretty persuasive don't you think
that was Jim Jones
the other side of that is the the
eccentricities that started to come out
over time and you talk about some of the
the services that he was doing later
were you know he would start talking
about how he had been annexed using
extraterrestrial and his life on other
planets and things like that and I was
fascinated reading this and and as you
know you pointed out it's really unfair
to his followers that some there's
something often depicted as kind of
mindless sheep
you know following him but I in read
I did find myself wondering you know how
it was that he would he would sometimes
go on these tangents that his followers
were willing to stick with him and I'm
guessing a lot of it was if they had
been with him for so long they've seen
his good work and they had gotten used
to some of some of the stranger things
that would sometimes come from him but
you also talk about how in the early 70s
his use of amphetamines and
tranquilizers start to get out of
control and I'm wondering how much of
the the the dark side that we think of
with Jim Jones was there and was with
and it was heading in that direction
anyway and how much was fueled by his
drug use in the 70s Jim Jones is always
a megalomaniac he always believes at
least to some extent that it's been
preordained that he would be great he
always lies he is really unthinking and
cruel to his wife he's selfish as he's
accomplishing these great things as he
gets more attention he is also getting
less criticism from those around him
when he does odd things when he maybe
overdoses on the amphetamines he says he
has to take because he needs to be awake
20 out of 24 hours a day to get so many
great things done it makes it easy to
say well that's Jim he performs faith
healings that her fake as the day gets
long and if you read this book I think
one of the interesting sections you
might find is how these faith healers
actually do produce these cancers that
they take from people's bodies hint
chicken parts
he sexually abused many of his followers
haven't we all seen then and today
examples of men in power who abuse that
with women it's disgusting and it's
cyclical as he began more and more to
become famous to achieve what he wanted
he began less and less to worry about
what impression he might be giving in
private for the way that he's acting
members of the church who disobey Him
can suffer terrible beatings
in front of everybody else he has sex
with the wife of one of his closest
followers they have a child there's a
whole lawsuit there's all kinds of legal
battles going on over custody of the
child so what he's Jim Jones he gets
what he wants
it was inevitable with all the bad
things he was doing and please
understand just because of all the great
accomplishments that doesn't in any way
negate the horrible things he's doing at
some point the media's going to catch up
with him and when they do Jones does two
things first of all he starts claiming
hang on this is a phrase that was used
back then I'm sure no one hears familiar
with it fake news
they're making it up they can't prove it
and as they started to prove it he would
continue saying they haven't proved it
at all until finally the heat got too
bad and there was a foreign farm
settlement in Guyana that People's
Temple had started and Jones was going
to escape there it was going to happen
demagogues in any form even if they're
promising their followers we're going to
make this a better world at some point
lead them to doom and one last point I'd
like to make quickly if you don't mind
her we're talking about why people would
follow him well okay we know all these
great things that are happening but
there's all the recall eccentricity of
Jim Jones how do you forgive that one of
the members of Peoples Temple in fact
one of the few remaining survivors of
that terrible day November 18th 1978
told me this story it's like the Frog
and a pot of water if you drop a frog in
a pot of boiling water is going to hop
out right away but if you sit the frog
in a pot of lukewarm water and turn up
the heat litter but little by little it
will almost allow itself to be boiled to
death please don't think when you read
about crazy Jim Jones at the end that he
was always exactly that way it was
incremental it happened over a number of
years and again the difference - between
him and other demagogues and followers
demagogues gained their following by
creating enemies out there if I'm the
only one they will say who can fix the
problems today there's all these people
that let's take this side of the rim no
offense these are the people who already
have everything they want what you've
got if you don't follow me they're going
to get everything you own
they're going to take it away they
create that tension the members of
People's Temple did not join because
they thought they were going to get
something they gave up everything they
owned joyfully the idea being they were
going to set an example of a group where
everybody is the same everyone is
treated alike and that example will be
so wonderful that the rest of the world
will see it and adopt it will finally
have a world where race doesn't matter
where money doesn't matter so they were
getting into this because they thought
ultimately for all the crap Jim Jones is
doing on the side he's still the one
who's going to lead us to this great
moment they did it at a generosity and
not selfishness now you write in the
book about once they got to Guyana if
the I hadn't thought of it from this
angle but now he's living amongst his
followers 24/7 they're really seeing
things that maybe they hadn't seen to
that to that degree when they were in
California and of course in the events
leading up to the the mass suicide you
had congressman Leo Ryan from California
visited he brought a group to see what
was going on some people wanted to leave
with him and then some Jones followers
ambushed them and shot and killed some
of the people who were true were at an
airstrip Jones responded by then
basically ordering this mass suicide
what what was the as you said their
people had now started to see a
different sides and maybe than they had
seen before when they were in California
what was what was the thinking if we can
kind of generalize about his followers
in those final hours and final days
before that tragic event now consider
the fact that you've got 900 people
living in the middle of one of the
densest most dangerous jungles in the
world I've been there I had to sort of
cut my way in with a machete I don't
advise you to do that it's not fun they
are out there in the middle of the
jungle and they have carved out 800
acres of a working farm all these years
since the government of Guyana has tried
to do the same thing it's never
exceeded only once a preacher from
America with a number of followers most
of whom had never even mowed a lawn they
did it that's leadership
this was Jim Jones's last chance to be
on the world stage and to prove that
under his leadership you could have a
socialist situation that the rest of the
world would want to follow the people
following him were up at 6:00 every
morning they're working out in the
fields
laboring until 5:00 at night their meals
are skimpy in the evenings they have to
go to a pavilion and listen to Jim Jones
preach for another four or five hours
they're getting maybe three or four
hours sleep a night they are physically
and mentally exhausted he has taken
their passports no one has any money he
says if you want to leave I guess you
can but we're not paying your way first
of all you'd have to find your way
through miles and miles of impenetrable
jungle and if you do get back to
civilization you have no passport or
money a group of concerned relatives in
America they've got family living in
Jonestown claim that their relatives are
being held against their will it's a
slave camp congressman Leo Ryan and
California goes to investigate taking
with him members of the media they get
to Jonestown and lo and behold a few
dozen people want to leave out of over
900 that's all the congressman is
astonished so maybe this isn't a slave
camp maybe most of the people do want to
be here so he says he'll take the ones
who want to leave take them home media
takes their picture does some interviews
when that group is about to leave some
of the leaders in Jonestown tell tell
Jim John sets that's pretty good you
know we're actually we've come away well
on this every one of those people belong
to Jim Jones and if it doesn't leave
today who knows how many
more or leaving now that this one
congressman has gotten in here more
people are coming it's over under his
orders men follow the congressman the
media the defectors to a little airstrip
they opened fire five are murdered dozen
more injured Jim Jones calls his
followers to the pavilion announces that
the congressman has been killed it
wasn't what Jones wanted but it happened
because these people loved him so much
they just did it the Army's coming in
there's nothing left we have to make a
gesture and so he wants everyone to line
up the children first the infants
they're going to go over it's going to
be simple it isn't cyanide poisoning is
horrible they died convulsive deaths
some people didn't want to do it he's
got a tape recorder going the whole time
you can hear the tape ultimately over
900 people are dead he's made his
gesture just like the little boy in Lynn
who thought Hitler did a fine thing
that's the horror and the tragedy is
that so many decent well-meaning people
died and so we learn from this we hope
well we've got about 10 minutes left
we're going to take some questions from
the audience if you have a question just
go to that mic there in the center of
the room and please we're really
counting on you we need some really in
question yes sir gray off I can remember
exactly when that occurred in November
78 I was in my car internal radio do you
remember where you were and what
happened can you tell us all about and
and how all your sure up thank you well
when when this happened in 1978 I was
living in Arlington Texas working for a
non-profit I had been a school teacher I
taught seventh grade English and I
caught myself thinking how could I ever
explain this to kids
because it was just so overwhelming like
everyone else the horror of it was so
vast that was all I could really think
about at the time and I could only think
what kind of fools would have followed a
man like this that's something I thought
right up to the point I started meeting
them and realized they weren't fools but
for people my age and I'm 65 I remember
three things above all else in my life
when Kennedy was assassinated I remember
Jim Jones and Peoples Temple and I
remember 9/11 and these I think are the
three great tragedies of modern American
history I wanted to understand this one
better I hope in reading my book maybe
that will happen for you folks - yes sir
Jeff I'd like to stray a little bit up
in the particulars of this book if I may
my question is in reading your books it
seems that your writing embodies the
single greatest trait that a writer
could possess and that is that each
sentence compels you to the next
sentence and the next sentence and the
next sentence and I'd like to know who
your influences were as a writer when I
was 8 I decided to be a writer because I
read my first book by John Steinbeck and
I thought someday I'm going to be able
to do that and my Steinbeck apex was
travels with Charlie if any of you have
read it
here's his fascinating book about a man
who gets in a truck with his dog drives
all around meets interesting people and
actually can write a book about it I
thought I want to get in on that
I never obviously became as great a
writer is John Steinbeck but I will tell
you this over my writing desk in Fort
Worth when I sold my first story to a
newspaper for $30 I used that money to
take a picture of John Steinbeck I cut
out of a magazine when I was 10 and I
had it framed and that picture is above
my writing desk and I look at it every
morning when I'm starting to work so
that's that's where I got it going from
Thank You John Steinbeck yes ma'am hello
so I haven't read the book yet but I
plan on doing it and when you talk about
Jones attachment issues do you believe
they arose from his family background or
do you believe he had abandonment issues
and young child or what do you
personally believe came about to these
attachment issues he had if we're going
to talk about the bad influence on Jim
Jones first of all I have to say it with
my last two books I've come to the
reluctant conclusion that it's actually
possible to be born bad enough that your
life will turn out in some horrific way
but Jim Jones had a mother who was so
alienated from everyone else and she's
got this kid in a little ramshackle home
every night telling him about how the
world is picking on her and on their
family and is out to get them it's
always the bosses you've got to fight
back I know because I had the vision
before your birth that you are going to
be the great man
and so he's hearing this when he's three
four or five years old and he's in a
small community where the whole idea is
everybody's supposed to be the same
that's the ambition he's the one person
besides mama who's a woman ostracized
because my god she smokes in public and
she doesn't wear dresses here you've got
this little kid going out there and from
the beginning thinking he's different
he's got to he wants to bring attention
to himself that's where it goes back to
I truly believe
yes sir Jeff I'm just curious I watched
a documentary last night holy hell it
was another kind of cultish kind of
place and I what I was wondering about
is because as a Reggie Manson book is
how did that affect you in your faith
like to me faith is one of the ways a
lot of us keep our sanity but when I
look at these things and it seems like I
don't know I just wondered how it
affected your faith looking at these
things if my faith is troubled by some
of the people I write about then my
faith is strengthened by some of the
people I meet when I'm writing in
writing about Jonestown and Peoples
Temple with some of the survivors who
spent the rest of their lives trying to
rebuild knowing them and seeing the
courage dev showed that restores any
faith that I might lose when I think
about Jones so yes sometimes it can be
shaken but it also gets reinforced yes
sir
I was wondering what you thought the
difference between communism and
socialism is sure with communism as it
was understood in those days that's when
the government said you have to live
this way it is forced socialism would be
more of a choice by society to have
certain traditions in certain ways of
doing things so the difference is
between choice and being ordered that's
the way it was looked at then there can
be all kinds of different definitions
but I'm talking about the broadest ones
under which People's Temple presented
themselves as socialists at that time
Jeff we've just got a couple of minutes
left and I apologize for throwing in
statute with so little time but what you
have a sense of what Jones if his life
hadn't taken a dark turn what he'd be
doing politically now he was he was
still alive I mean we talk about
demagogues and we've experienced a few
I'm a fair question all all religious
leaders all politicians to a sense or
demagogues they're trying to create a
sense of urgency vote for me join my
church Jones towards the
end of this time in San Francisco and
this scares the hell out of me had
started talking about public office and
the way was saying Reverend Jones says
he doesn't yet have time but you've got
to remember he's and he's a national
figure and he's around vice presidents
first ladies governors and certainly his
thinking he's greater than they are I'll
tell you this if Jim Jones had wanted to
go into politics it had been good at it
and he wouldn't have aimed low and if
you say oh that's ridiculous no one like
Jim Jones who had no political
experience was only a performer and
claimed only he could save the world you
think he could be elected president the
United States never harka what a fool
you are I think we need to study the
life of Jim Jones so we can learn
lessons that would be helpful to us in
making our choices today thank you well
thank you thank you Jeff Wynn and thank
you for coming
[Applause]